when I arrived at TCM in September of
2003 that was 16 years ago Robert
Osborne was already at that point a
legit legend he signed the channel on
the air in April of 1994 or 25 years ago
he wasn't just synonymous with TCM he
was synonymous with classic movies as
I've often said Robert was the Walter
Cronkite of TCM he was the he was the
Babe Ruth of TCM he was the George
Washington of TCM so so then I come in
and I was like the Ron Burgundy of TCM
the Bob Uecker of TCM the I can't think
of a really terrible president right now
I'm sure maybe maybe one will come to me
so not surprisingly I think it's fair to
say that when I arrived Robert was like
maybe a little bit nonplussed you know
there was this younger kid with a goatee
and who'd seen All About Eve
considerably less than he had and my
uncle wrote and directed it so you know
again I think he didn't love it fully
when I arrived but now in the last like
two years
TCM has hired three new hosts and so
like now I totally get it like enough I
got it so right away I learned what what
Robert meant to TCM you know we didn't
actually see each other that often
because at that point we couldn't shoot
at the same time so if I was in Atlanta
Robert couldn't be in Atlanta and
vice-versa but we worked in the same
space we worked they our sets were built
in the same studio we had the same
wardrobe stylist we had the same makeup
artist we lived in the same space we had
the same producers two of them are here
tonight and Wilson and Gary Friedman
with Robert really almost from the start
maybe from the start and I love all
these people love them love them and
they loved Robert and they revered
Robert so like through them I was like
this guy is magical I mean the way these
people talk about him that was really my
first sense of what he was so what randy
said that if you judge someone by their
friends you get a really good indication
of who they are I knew all of Roberts
friends in Atlanta they they couldn't
have helped me more they are so
important to me and they adored him so
then my challenge not is trying to fill
these shoes was not to imitate Robert to
sort of develop my own style and I sort
of came to realize that much of that was
impossible because every TCM host
follows a template that Robert Osborn
created we talked about the four C's at
TCM curation context connection and
community you know Robert he curated the
movies giving us context so we could
appreciate them in the right way as the
panel pointed out and then forming a
meaningful connection with this growing
passionate TCM community that's all
Robert Robert didn't hire me he didn't
hire Eddie Muller he didn't hire Alicia
Malone he didn't hire Dave Karger he
didn't hire Jacqueline Stewart but all
of us are his protegees none of us will
ever have his knowledge his talent and
as we heard tonight that commanding
stage presence that you felt whether you
saw him live or you watched him for two
and a half minutes before a movie and a
minute after the movie I'm so grateful
that Robert and I got to know each other
and connect in the last three or four
years of his life and while he left us
too soon
he left TCM strong
then it's ever been he left it never
having had a more profound connection
with that audience and never playing a
more critical role in keeping these
great movies in the public consciousness
so at the beginning of this little brief
talk which is now fortunately near
attend I called Robert a legit legend as
some of the people who work at TCM know
that's a word that I have pretty much
banned from scripts because we overuse
it and then if you call everybody a
legend then there are no legends but you
know we all know there are some la Betty
Davis Bogart John Wayne Sidney Poitier
Joan Crawford Judy Garland Cary Grant
many more those are legit legends I
think it is fair to say that that Robert
Osborne is also alleged